In order for a phoenix to be reborn, it first
has to die.
And that's what Dark Phoenix is essentially
about: the death of the X-Men franchise at
Fox, so it may be gloriously reborn at Marvel
Studios.
But, wow, do we have some questions!
Here's a spoiler-filled look at the biggest
unanswered questions in Dark Phoenix.
At the beginning of Dark Phoenix, the X-Men
go on a mission to save some astronauts menaced
by a weird space cloud.
"he is here."
No, not that weird space cloud.
Not that one either.
This is a totally different space cloud that
turns out to be the Phoenix Force.
And then bad things happen for two hours.
But that raises a big question: didn't Jean
already have the Phoenix Force?
Like, just in the last movie?
"unleash your power!
Let go, Jean!
Jean, let go!"
X-Men: Apocalypse was set in 1983, a full
nine years before the events of Dark Phoenix.
So if she just got the Phoenix Force now,
what the heck was that all about?
At the climax of the film, the U.S. government
decides to crack down on mutants, rounding
up all the X-Men in a campaign to imprison
mutants in concentration camps.
The X-Men break free in a massive battle.
But then what?
Yes, somehow after violently destroying a
government train and leveling the countryside,
at the cost of numerous U.S. military lives,
the X-Men are then shown being totally fine
back at school.
So what happened?
And what about all the other mutants in America,
like the refugees on Magneto's island?
Are they all still huddling in a mutant camp
somewhere under armed guard?
Out of sight, out of mind, apparently.
Remember X-Men: Days of Future Past?
In that film, the future turned to hot poop,
so the cast from the original X-Men trilogy
sent Hugh Jackman into the prequel trilogy
to create a new timeline where the future
was nice.
It sort of worked.
He saved his Jean Grey… but apparently doomed
this other version, because now the prequels
aren't prequels anymore, they're a totally
different timeline.
It's a timeline where time itself doesn't
seem to work anymore.
Remember that X-Men: First Class was set way
back in 1963.
That means that characters like Magneto, Xavier,
and Mystique should all be in their 50s or
early 60s by the time Dark Phoenix comes around
in 1992.
And yet, they don't seem to have aged a day
in 30 years.
Even characters like Storm and Cyclops who
first appeared in Apocalypse, are still the
exact same age nine years later.
Between the original X-Men films, these not-actually-prequels,
whatever Days of Future Past was, and Logan,
there seem to be four distinct X-Men timelines.
So congrats!
The movies are finally as confusing as the
comics.
A lot has been written about the end of Dark
Phoenix, which reportedly was totally changed
at the last minute because the original ending
was way too similar to Captain Marvel.
And the haste shows, because the big battle
on the train leaves a lot of questions, the
main one being: What happened to all the aliens
Jean didn't kill?
These aliens seemed to be nearly invulnerable,
shrugging off bullets and mutant attacks with
ease.
But, like, two dozen of them are simply knocked
off the train by optic blasts from Cyclops,
or a strong wind from Storm.
Given how tough they are, it seems likely
that most of those aliens survived a simple
fall.
So what happened with them?
Are they still on Earth?
Did they get back on their missing spaceship
and fly away?
And is anyone ever going to comment on the
fact that there are ALIENS on Earth?
Guess we'll never know!
Speaking of Days of Future Past, remember
this?
"they told me you can control metal."
"they?"
"you know, my mom once knew a guy who could
do that.
And what about this bit from Apocalypse?
"I'm your…
I'm here for my family too."
Yes, the fact that Quicksilver is secretly
Magneto's son is a major subplot.
In fact, it's the only character development
for Quicksilver in all three films combined.
So we have to ask: Did they ever have that
dang talk?
Unfortunately, we don't know, because Quicksilver
disappears from Dark Phoenix less than halfway
through it.
Magneto, meanwhile, heads off to Europe to
check out the amateur chess scene.
And since this is likely the last time we'll
see these versions of the characters, it seems
we'll never find out whether they ever got
closure.
One thing is certain, though: the viewers
definitely didn't!
After the final credits roll on Dark Phoenix,
the first question many X-Men fans have is:
Why was this movie made?
We're not being snarky.
We're just wondering why, with over 55 years
of great X-Men stories to choose from, Fox
decided to tell the Dark Phoenix story twice
in seven films.
Especially considering 2006's The Last Stand
is considered the worst X-Men film of them
all.
Well… it was until now, anyway!
The fact is that there are so many superhero
films in theaters these days that fans want
and need to see something new.
Why they didn't get something new here is
a question we may never get an answer to.
Finally, the biggest unanswered question of
them all is simply: now what?
Technically, there's still one more X-Men
film coming from Fox the horror-tinged spinoff
New Mutants, which has been delayed and pushed
back on the schedule repeatedly, and which
is currently set to debut on April 3, 2020.
After that, though, it's just a matter of
time before Marvel Studios does something
with the X-Men.
Thanks to their deal with Fox, Marvel Studios
films couldn't even mention the whole concept
of mutants, so we're not sure how they'll
bring the X-Men into the mix.
And it's also likely that Marvel will want
to completely recast the characters, meaning
fans might be meeting their third Jean Grey
and their third Storm in as many decades.
It's a big ask for the audience, though Marvel
proved with Tom Holland and Spider-Man that
they can make it work.
The ashes are here.
We're just waiting to see how the resurrection
goes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.